[Music]
on this friday night was the bus crash
on alberta's columbia ice fields an
accident waiting to happen it's really
really scary
as the company defends its record two
former employees allege alarming safety
issues
there's like a constant problem that
just doesn't get fixed
the young and the reckless call out your
friends
if they're not feeling well targeting
the messaging to those who are ignoring
public health rules more complaints
about the governor general
the former employee backing up claims of
a toxic work culture
and keeping the olympic dream alive i'm
grateful to be in the position that i'm
in canadian athletes practice patience
during the pandemic
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the full analysis of what happened to
that tourist bus on the columbia ice
fields in alberta
the one that rolled down a steep
embankment killing three people and
injuring 24
others won't be complete for months but
global news has spoken to former drivers
of the specially designed ice explorer
buses
and they say potential safety issues
like leaking coolant and oil
were routinely flagged by drivers and
then ignored
global news has agreed to conceal their
identities because their concerns
speaking out could affect their careers
jamie dahl reports i just could picture
just how scary that would have been not
only for the driver but for the
passengers
he sat in the driver's seat of a pursuit
ice explorer for an entire season
shuttling tourists through the
ever-changing landscape of the columbia
ice field
was his very first job as a professional
driver
last weekend's deadly crash there a
disaster he says he long
feared would become a reality it's
really really scary
and um you know it happened to me that
i went down the brain out of control
once and that was really scary and i
could feel
you know my adrenaline pump and when i
heard about what happened
he says in that case his transmission
lockup failed going down a steep hill
but he managed to keep it from going off
course there's one day i think right
three different buses i've put into
because the bus i was in kept breaking
up yeah
so um mechanical issues happened like
all the time there was one point where
i had a bus just shut off just as i was
get
about to get to the turnaround point
where people walk around the former
icefields driver alleges the buses were
notorious for leaking coolant in
engine oil and overheating he says
emergency windows often didn't open
and while drivers were required to do
daily inspection reports
he claims maintenance wasn't a top
priority
he's not the only former driver raising
concerns
this woman says the bus she was driving
skidded backwards with a full busload
because there was just not enough tread
on the tires there's like
a constant like problem that
just doesn't get fixed by mechanics
whether it's there's not enough
mechanics or whatever it's like there's
just
so many incidences that would just close
calls and it's i don't know
it's horrible it's horrible she had come
from australia
and admits she had never even driven on
an icy highway before getting behind the
wheel of an ice explorer
i did feel like we were trained quite
well
uh as being a driver
to the extent if everything is sunny do
you know what i mean like if everything
is going a okay
then yeah you are equipped to be a
driver and to do
like a good tour and have all the jokes
but if things went bad she says she
didn't feel experienced enough to know
what to do
global news contacted pursuit the
company who now manages these buses
pursuit did not answer questions about
the specific allegations but said in a
statement
we stand by our 39 years of operation
where we have safely guided over 16
million passengers across the terrain
and pride ourselves on our commitment to
training and passenger safety
and our strong track record of safety
the rcmp
transportation safety board and parks
canada are investigating
jamie daw global news banff alberta
the identity of another victim from that
crash is now confirmed a family friend
identified grieva patel a nursing
graduate from
india as one of the three victims killed
in the crash and supplied these photos
to global news
she had been in canada for a year and a
half and her friend says she was hoping
to begin a new life here
as people slowly start to fly again
there's a new warning tonight about one
of the most popular passenger planes
u.s federal safety regulators have
issued an emergency air worthiness
directive for thousands of boeing 737s
that have been parked during the
pandemic faa inspectors found problems
with air check valves that could lead
to dual engine failure in flight the
federal aviation administration is
ordering all
operators of boeing 737s to inspect
engine valves in jets
that have been sitting idle for more
than a week inspectors found corrosion
in the valves of planes
being taken out of storage the faa took
the action after four recent reports of
single engine shutdowns due to check
valves being stuck
open transport canada says the same
inspections will be done on 205 of the
canadian aircraft
this has nothing to do with the boeing
737 max which has been grounded since
march
2019 after two fatal crashes
there's a warning tonight from canada's
chief public health officer dr teresa
tam says not only
is canada's covid19 curve headed in the
wrong direction
a growing number of younger people are
getting sick
in the last week more than 60 percent of
newly reported cases were people
under the age of 39 and nearly a third
of them
had to be hospitalized i must urge all
canadians
particularly younger adults to not give
into covet 19 fatigue this is your
generation and your future that is being
shaped
keeping track of who has been exposed is
key to limiting the spread
and today after weeks of delays a new
smartphone
contact tracing app is finally in beta
testing
it's designed to warn users if they've
been in close contact with someone who
tested positive for covid19
you can sign up to help test the app
through the canadian digital service
as heather urix west explains getting
young people to listen not just about
that
app but to all the messaging about
public health restrictions
is a big hurdle it's a plea being echoed
across the country
this needs to be a wake-up call what
more can i say
you know be responsible call out your
friends
if they're not feeling well after months
under lockdown
young people are hitting the town at
bars restaurants parties and gyms
and covet 19 infections are on the rise
we've seen the number of contacts that
each individual case
has go from where it was about six
a few months ago to more like 15 now so
there's
a larger number of people that
individuals are coming into contact with
for contact tracers that's a challenge
especially in situations where people
don't know who they've come into contact
with in alberta where active cases have
more than doubled in just a few
weeks hospitals are feeling the strain
and it's not just
older adults needing care our current
acute care utilization
is approaching the highest number of
admissions on any single day that we
have had
we're seeing cases in younger in younger
patients the younger populations now
we're seeing
mainly the 20 to 29 and you know 30 to
39
age groups so which is not not
surprising with
people getting out and doing more it's
why several provinces are now looking at
ways to try and turn things around
since march the bc government has been
partnering with the vancouver canucks to
target its messaging to young people
through social media
the province says it plans to start
enlisting the help of other social media
influencers soon
too we can gather we can chill just no
hugs and kisses
two meters apart we can still talk and
listen and in quebec
ads featuring rapper zak zoya began
airing this week
alberta says it's working on a new
strategy to target young people as well
the hope
is that better communication will start
changing habits
before public health officials are
forced to start shutting things down
a second time heather urex west global
news calgary
older people are hit hardest by covet 19
but no one should think they're immune
coming up the story of a 30 year old
toronto man who spent eight weeks on a
ventilator
and he has a message for younger
canadians
in the united states there are now so
many covet 19 hot spots that a top white
house advisor is urging all americans to
wear masks
because the terrible outbreak in new
york in late march
is now being repeated elsewhere and i
just want to make it clear to the
american public
what we have right now are essentially
three new yorks with these three
major states
she is referring to florida california
and texas where more than 500 people
died yesterday alone
as case numbers surge more and more
hospitals are overwhelmed
jackson proskow has the latest from
washington
there are now more people hospitalized
with covet 19
in the u.s than at any other time state
after state
is setting daily records for the number
of deaths
in star county texas where the local
hospital is running at 300 percent
capacity
patients who are most likely to succumb
to the virus will now be
sent home to die we are not
gods we are not anybody to take a
decision of who
should live or who should die across the
u.s the rapid growth in new cases has
been driven largely by young people
experts warn that won't last in a few
weeks maybe
a month or so increased infections in
older people will be seen
a worrying trend as the white house
pushes schools to reopen
the children obviously have a very
strong
immune system despite all the unknowns
about how children are impacted
and how that might put their parents or
teachers at risk
we certainly know from other studies
that children under 10
do get infected it's just unclear how
rapidly they spread the virus
with so many hot spots and cases on the
rise in most of the u.s
president donald trump has recently been
forced to bend to the reality of the
pandemic
he canceled the republican convention in
florida where he was set to accept his
party's nomination in august
while places that have already beat back
the virus once
fear the threats of a resurgence
washington d.c
and massachusetts have joined new york
in ordering anyone coming from nearly 30
hard-hit
states to quarantine for two weeks
jackson prosko global news washington
back in this country governor general
julie payette says she supports an
investigation into allegations
of workplace harassment made against her
the privy council office which
coordinates and supports all departments
and agencies of the federal government
will conduct the probe
in a statement payette says i take
harassment and workplace issues very
seriously and i am in full agreement and
welcome an independent review
mike look a tour on what we know about
the complaints and what happens
next all is quiet at the residence of
the governor general
a stark contrast to what some former
employees have described as a toxic
atmosphere
inside rideau hall the vibe at the
you know the stress the constant barrage
the it was just it was unbearable
one former employee agreed to speak with
us on the condition they remained
anonymous but their experience
echoes reports of alleged abuse of
treatment by both
governor general julie payet and her
secretary asunta dilorenzo
who also happens to be payette's
longtime friend
when they were together in meetings they
would gang up together
they would they would barrage
people the former employee says they'd
see
someone leave dilorenzo's office crying
at least once a week
the privy council office says it will
conduct a thorough
independent and impartial review to
examine the concerns raised by past
and current employees of the office of
the secretary
to the governor general in a statement
payette welcomed the review
saying she is deeply concerned with the
media reports but former staffers said
the complaint process is a closed loop
it's hard to be objective and it's hard
for other employees
to think that they're going to be
treated fairly if they have a if they
have a conflict
with in this case your best friend so
should payette step down well that's a
decision for the prime minister to make
if he so wishes it won't be a donald
trump style
tweet saying you're fired right it it
will be a discreet conversation between
the prime minister and and the governor
general
if it came down to it despite multiple
people coming forward
publicly to complain a spokesperson for
the governor general says there have
been no
formal complaints regarding harassment
at rideau hall
mike lacouter global news ottawa
canadians reflect on the extent of
systemic racism
coming up the new poll showing how
attitudes have evolved
2020 has so far been a tumultuous year
around the world
the pandemic combined with the calls for
racial justice have led to lots of
reevaluation
of our society and our attitudes and now
a new ipsos poll done exclusively for
global news shows canadian attitudes on
racism
have shifted sixty percent of canadians
surveyed said they feel racism is a
serious problem in this country
that's up 13 points over last year mike
relay takes a deeper look at what the
poll reveals
about systemic racism
[Applause]
it had to be big to push covet 19 out of
the headlines
a resounding call for societal change
proved to be just that
are we going to keep going down this
route or are we going to
come up with some innovative humane
kind compassionate ways of being with
each other
and with the earth in an exclusive ipsos
poll conducted for global news
it appears canadians are ready to listen
in fact a 63
say they support the black lives matter
protests whatever the reason
the message of equality seems to be
getting through even as the number of
canadians who say they've experienced
racism firsthand
continues to rise having you know lived
with uh
racism for 65 years um
i i have a lot of hope when i hear that
it didn't happen overnight and so it's
not going to go away overnight in fact
the ipsos pool found that 17 percent of
canadians are unsure what they believe
and that they can't say they're not
racist what they are
sure about is everybody else 54
believe everyone is a little racist and
that belief system is an important
element
dexter voicing who wrote america the
beautiful and violent
says racism is deeply ingrained in our
psyches
whether we know it or not for those that
do they certainly seemed ashamed
49 percent say they think racist
thoughts
but they'd never talk about them in
public the very sometimes the very
denial
of racism allows racism to continue so
very often i've had
conversations with well-educated
colleagues and they'll say yeah racism
exists but not in our organization
so folks are apt to see racism in other
spaces
but then we have blind spots when it
comes to how we contribute to a system
of racism
but he too is hopeful change is on the
horizon the ground swell is too deep and
vast
to ignore any more microlight global
news toronto
turning 30 with covid 19 ahead a young
survivor's warning and his long road to
recovery
it's been said time and time again that
most people who get very sick with kovid
19 and most people who die
are over the age of 60 but that does not
mean younger people are immune
they get infected too and can not only
pass it on to older people
they can get so sick they end up in
intensive care
tonight karen lieberman has the
cautionary tale of a 30 year old who
thought he'd be
just fine
it's been nearly three months since
delroy noble walked into this toronto
area hospital
after testing positive for covid19 i
remember
waking up and i was unable to breathe it
was like
very very difficult he left his job at
pearson international airport in april
with cold symptoms
when he spiked a fever he suspected it
could be the novel coronavirus i believe
i got my mother sick my aunt's sick
and my younger brothers say because they
all tested positive as well
delroy went to the emergency department
and within two days his condition
worsened
there was a consult to the critical care
team
and ended up in the icu was intubated
ontario is seeing a spike in cases of
coven 19 in the 20 to 39
age group delroy marked his 30th
birthday
here in hospital on a ventilator the
general population that comes in with
kovid
is usually older he's one of the younger
ones
for 59 days delroy was hooked up to a
ventilator
the medical team was hopeful but
uncertain of his future
i think given his age that he did come
to us
with less comorbidities some of our
older coronavirus patients did come with
hypertension diabetes
cardiac risk factors as well when the
breathing tube was removed and delroy
opened his eyes
his sister was there to greet him i
remember her telling me it's june 30th
it's like you were in a coma for two
months besides feeling weak and unable
to walk
delroy felt lighter he lost a lot of
weight
roughly 130 pounds
might have gained back a few though
because the food here is pretty good
he hasn't lost his sense of humor but
delroy does have a serious message for
other young adults
don't take this for a joke because
personally when the
pandemic first started i thought that
hey i'm a young man
if i get it i'm just gonna get a cold
when i fell unconscious that day on may
5th
for all you know you i could have died
that day karen lieberman
global news toronto
next final countdown planning for tokyo
2021
how is team canada coping
well it's pretty clear dr anthony fauci
is in the right profession even he
admits that pitch was
a little off the mark america's top
infectious disease doctor got the honor
of throwing the first pitch last night
to kick off
the baseball season and after being told
they can't play in toronto because of
kovid 19 concerns the toronto blue jays
now say they'll play the majority of
their home games in buffalo
new york the pandemic has put a wrench
into many sports plans the olympic games
were supposed to start in tokyo this
week
instead the countdown is now on for next
summer
as crystal gamansing explains
it's the last weekend in july many of us
have lost
track of the days but not olympic-bound
athletes like dana pedroski
i'm grateful to be in the position that
i'm in
where i know i have a spot
and at the same time i sort of am
viewing this delay as
just another year to get stronger if it
wasn't for the pandemic venues for the
summer games
would be packed instead we are now
one year out and the countdown is on
the olympic games are the most complex
event
on this planet we have to get together
11 000
athletes but some people don't want the
games to go ahead
part of the issue is cost with the
postponement conservative estimates peg
the cost of the games
at around 15 billion dollars there's
also doubt they can be held
safely given the continued spread of
covet 19.
you train for four years eight years 12
years you commit
everything you have with the hope
to compete with the hope to win
three-time olympic gold medalist marnie
mcbean knows
all about the roller coaster of emotions
the chef de michonne tried to reflect
that in her latest
letter to the athletes her plans were
garbaged in
in march but our goals weren't our goals
remain the same
the only thing i can do is focus on what
i can control and that's
working hard and trying to be the best
athlete that i can be
that means staying healthy and training
where
and whenever it's possible crystal
gonadsing global news
london and that is global national for
this friday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is london ontario just north
of lake erie
thanks for watching i'll see you again
next week take care of yourselves
bye-bye